how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
before we get started i must issue a
spoiler warning for the indian of
spider-man knowing home and the post
credit scenes which we are about to talk
about but if you've seen them or you are
simply ready for the spoilers let's go
ahead and get started in spider-man no
way home peter goes to doctor strange to
ask him to cast a spell to make
everybody forget that peter parker is
spider-man strange starts to cast the
spell and says that everyone is going to
forget that peter is spider-man but
peter quickly realizes that people
should still know at least some people
like his girlfriend mj his best friend
ned his aunt may happy hogan so strange
rewrites the spell a bunch until it
eventually gets out of control but
doctor strange is able to contain it
however as we would soon go on to find
out strange wasn't able to contain all
of it some villains ended up breaking
through instead of making people forget
that peter parker was spider-man it
actually brought people who knew peter
was spider-man into the universe and
this started to break reality by the end
of the movie the spell ends up getting
let loose and doctor strange cannot hold
all of the people back coming from other
realities so in a true peter parker act
he puts everybody else in front of him
and says make everyone forget that i am
spider-man no exceptions everyone
strange casts the spell and it seemingly
works by the end of the movie nobody
remembers that peter parker is
spider-man in fact it seems like nobody
really remembers peter at all which i'll
talk about in a different video but it
looks like this does not come without
consequences to dr strange as the second
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home is a trailer for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness and it looks
to be one of the best trailers that i've
ever seen from marvel studios but first
let's talk about that first venom
post-credits scene now the venom let
there be carnage post-credit scene
brought venom and eddie brock into the
mcu and i know what some people might be
thinking how did they get brought in by
dr strange's spell if eddie brock didn't
know who spider-man was let alone that
peter parker was spider-man well keep in
mind that venom did say that he had
billions of years of hive knowledge so
i'm willing to bet that it was actually
venom who knew that peter parker was
spider-man and not eddie brock in fact
it looked like eddie brock didn't even
know who spider-man was at all so i'll
credit venom with knowing who peter
parker was however this moment is
short-lived as when doctor strange does
the spell that makes everybody forget
that peter parker is spider-man sending
them back to their own universes we see
eddie and venom go back however a part
of the venom symbiote does stay behind
which means eventually this is going to
go on to bond with spider-man aka peter
parker and it looks like we may get a
more comic accurate venom story in the
mcu at some point in time and that's
pretty much the gist of the first post
credit scene there is a venom symbiote
inside of the marvel cinematic universe
now without eddie brock and the actual
venom that we've seen in the sony
universe setting a path for a different
new venom to appear in the marvel
cinematic universe and the next
post-credit scene like i said is a
trailer for dr strange 2 doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness now the
second post credit scene
trailer starts off with a black screen
we hear ominous music playing in the
background and then we hear wong we hear
him say don't cast that spell it's too
dangerous now we didn't actually hear
wang say this in the actual movie but we
did hear him say it in one of the
trailers for spider-man no way home we
then hear dr strange say we tampered
with the stability of space-time we see
some candles blow out at the comartage
and then we hear dr strain say the
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little which is
exactly what he told peter in spider-man
no way home this implies that there are
severe consequences to what he did in no
way home that are now coming to fruition
in multiverse of madness this is also
demonstrated in the very next scene that
we get we see doctor strange's old watch
this is the one watch that he kept and
did not sell he had it the entire time
even after he became a sorcerer it was
broken and reflects the fact that he
himself was broken his hands no longer
worked and now we can see his reflection
in the watch in this post-credits scene
still shattered reflecting that he
himself is indeed still shattered and
the multiverse is now shattered as well
and unfortunately as the watch reflects
it is doctor strange himself who has
shattered the reality that he knows this
is further confirmed as we then hear
mordo say your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished if you recall in
the doctor strange film morda was kind
of devastated that the ancient one was
using dark magic in the film he says she
drew on its power to steal centuries of
life but she told them that it was
forbidden while she did that and then he
said the bill comes due it always comes
due which is now happening with doctor
strange and all of his actions the bill
is coming due including apparently what
he did in avengers infinity war and
avengers end game as the next part we
hear is doctor strange's line from
avengers infinity war right before he
snapped it was the only way referring to
him giving up the time stone now this
implies that there are a lot of things
here that are actually responsible for
shattering the multiverse hence
multiverse of madness it's not just what
happened in spiderman no way home but
it's also what happened in doctor
strange the first movie also what
happened in avengers infinity war and
end game after all the ancient one
explained in avengers infinity war in
2012 when hulk went back and talked to
her she explained that if you remove one
infinity stone from a universe that
would tamper with the flow of time and
that their world would be overrun and
millions would suffer without their
chief weapon against the powers of
darkness referring to the infinity
stones and this is actually exactly what
is happening right now the infinity
stones no longer exist in our universe
they were destroyed by thanos in fact
this is even a point that is made during
spider-man no way home when peter
originally goes to doctor strange and
asks him to reverse time dr strange said
even if he would be willing he doesn't
have the time stone anymore the chief
weapon against the power of darkness
that the ancient one mentioned we see
doctor strange go through a gate in
which new york seems to be kind of
falling apart this actually looks like
exactly what we saw in the what if
episode where doctor strange and stream
supreme were in what if episode four
doctor strange bypassed an absolute
point in time this affected the universe
and essentially made it start going away
and eventually that universe did
completely go away it sort of dissipated
into nothingness which seems to be what
is happening right here now as far as
absolute points in time are concerned
doctor strange could have actually
bypassed several of them possibly
affecting infinite amounts of different
universes he gave up the time stone
which the ancient one did call their
chief weapon and even though infinity
war and endgame made it seem like it was
supposed to happen perhaps there are
some big consequences that follow up
with that plus not to mention his spell
did cause the sinister five to come into
spider-man knowing home and the main mcu
timeline doc ock green goblin electro
sandman and the lizard all have very
different fates now when they go back to
their own universes they were all
supposed to die or get locked up in a
prison however they are now cured and
they are back in their original
universes their fates have drastically
changed not to mention the fates of
their spidermans have changed as well
for example when norman osborne goes
back he's no longer going to be the
green goblin this will cause harry to no
longer turn into goblin and die this
will have huge implications on toby
maguire spider-man and that's just one
case alfred molina is going to go back
and his doc ock is not going to die as
well the repercussions of what happened
and spiderman no way home are going to
be huge and this is why doctor strange
is going to have to pay for them he
could have broken multiple absolute
points in time causing not only his
universe but possibly infinite amounts
of universes to start to collapse but
then a lot happens in this trailer we
see doctor strange enter a very dark
sanctum one that is flooded with water
we hear him say the words but i never
meant for any of this to happen he is
clearly talking to somebody that is
accusing him of being responsible for
all of this the fabric of reality
essentially melting now we could be
talking to wang he could be talking to
mordo or he could be talking to somebody
else there's rumors that the illuminati
could show up in multiverse of madness
and it's possible that they kind of
govern the multiverse and they could be
super pissed at him we see a shot of
wanda's hand using some chaos magic then
we see dr christine palmer walking down
the aisle and get this stephen strange
doctor strange is not waiting for her he
is actually in the pew the look on her
face as she walks down makes it seem
like she might have a little bit regret
of what she's about to do not mary and
steven strange and strange doesn't look
too happy as well but at the end of the
doctor strange film they kind of left
their own separate ways as friends we
then see a woman from behind wearing a
star on the back of her jacket this is
america chavez played by soshi gomez who
i actually met and had the pleasure to
talk to you for a little bit at the
shangshi and the legend of the tin rings
premiere now her powers are that she's
able to open up star portals to
different dimensions so this is kind of
a perfect movie for her to enter here
one where the multiverse is in madness
and it looks like doctor strange is
going to try and fix it america chavez
aka miss america is definitely going to
be a key asset we then see a very beat
up wong who looks like he's having a
rough time we then see somebody falling
through a portal of a shattered reality
and which i originally thought was
doctor strange but it kind of looks like
they have a ponytail here so maybe not
strange but if you look hard enough you
can definitely tell that that portal is
a star portal so it was created by
america chavez we then cut to the big
scene doctor strange goes and he finds
wanda she says i knew sooner or later
you'd show up and she starts talking
about the mistakes that she made in one
division in west view but dr strain says
i'm not here to talk about westview
wanna then ask what are you here for and
he says how much do you know about the
multiverse we need your help in which
wanda looks very surprised but we know
that wanda actually probably knows quite
a bit about the multiverse at this point
at the end of wanda vision in the
post-credits scene we saw the scarlet
witch astral projecting and learning
about other universes about different
realities because she was searching for
her kids we actually heard the doctor
strange theme music playing in the
background of this scene she was
searching the dark hold and actually
learning very dark magic all of course
to find her kids and what she finally
did here at the very end but since she
was using astral projection to study we
could probably assume that she's read
the entire darkhold which means that she
has been tampering with dark magic this
is something that mordo said was pretty
forbidden and even in a few scenes later
we see a picture of her as the full
scarlet witch we see her in the middle
of a seance surrounded by candles and
rumor has it that she is going to be
somewhat of a villain in multiverse of
madness now we're not really sure who
the main villain is at this point in
time but we do know that she really
wants to find her children and she has
been learning very dark magic so she's
going to be insanely powerful and she is
the scarlet witch now fully unlocked
which makes her even more powerful and
we know that she's probably going to
stop at nothing to find her children
even if that means having to fight
doctor strange but we'll have to wait
and see on that we then have a scene
where doctor strange comes out of a door
now the base of this door is kind of
floating in another reality it's hard to
tell what place this is but it could be
the home of america chavez the utopian
parallel the utopian parallel is a
dimension that exists in parallel to all
other dimensions of the multiverse it is
actually out of time and outside of the
multiverse as well we see strange
looking out of the door and behind him
we can see america's chavez and we can
see wanda we then see mordo and we hear
him say i'm sorry steven then darkness
and clouds go over the camara taj
strange and wong look insanely worried
we see the shots of the scarlet witch
that i talked about before and as we see
mordo and doctor strange fighting each
other we hear him say i hope you
understand and as he says this we see
doctor strange kind of casting some red
magic that looks an awful lot like
wanda's chaos magic and these little
orbs kind of look like perhaps different
universes different worlds all connected
to each other perhaps doctor strange
trying to do some damage control to what
wanda has done or he himself has done we
then see one of the villains of
multiverse of madness what we thought
was going to be schumachorth is actually
gargantos now i've spoken about
gargantos before not a very well-known
villain in fact he's only appeared in a
couple of comic issues but is associated
with namor the submariner of atlantis if
the illuminati is going to appear in
multiverse of madness it is possible
that namor could appear as well as he is
part of the illuminati this could
explain how gargantos arrives or they
could simply change the entire comic
story altogether and gargantos could
simply be a multi-dimensional villain it
throws a bus at doctor strange and
america chavez but doctor strange is
able to protect both of them by casting
the spell and cutting the bus in half
then as we hear mordo finally finish the
sentence which started off as i'm sorry
steven i hope you understand the
greatest threat to our universe is you
and as he says this we see an alternate
sanctum which i'm assuming exists in
another universe or perhaps in between
universes in the background it looks
like this could be some type of void i'm
actually getting a lot of loki vibes
here when they finally run into he who
remains but here we meet another doctor
strange which could be strange supreme
we were introduced to strange supreme in
what if episode 4 and also in the finale
as well it is possible that what if
could connect to the live action films
however i'm probably going to say that
this is just a different variant of
doctor strange which i think we might
see a few of these in the movie this one
does seem to be a lot darker and could
be a lot more evil we could probably
assume that if doctor strange is at the
heart of the multiverse breaking it's
not just one doctor strange but multiple
ones and we can assume that there are
going to be some evil ones and the
trailer ends with this strange saying
things just got out of hand and i don't
know about you all but i am super
excited for this movie doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness looks like
it's going to be phenomenal so let me
know all your thoughts and theories
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe if you love
marvel and the mcu and want more content
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you